[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants beaux soirs je peux
y aller patron sûr qu'on va chabut jeux
wii nounours mais tu ne dois pas triché
tu as bien compris voyons pas trop je le
triche jamais vous savez tiens tu
nous verrons mon le jeune
homme photo pom pom pom
boy soir les petits
vous voulez jouer avec moi
non les enfants pas de jeu pas pas nous
allons jouer aux cartes
nous allons jouer au bridge
ou paris
bon alors nous allons faire une petite
boulotte
[Rires]
bon que diriez-vous d'une petite partie
de rabbi ou de cadastre
et bien nous allons faire une bataille
mois chez moi
[Musique]
je ne les regarde pas
allons à toi nicolas
à moi
l'as de carreau chez moi tu gagnes
je continue
un deux de pique au
rouge bateau
et moi tout genre je connus
oui alors tu as touché tu as joué un
quart mois bon c'est nicolas qui a
triché
c'est scandaleux j'ai gagné
oui patron j'arrive
je me sauve les petits allez vite vous
couchez juste pas malheureux pour une
fois que ce gars
notre agent ben
voilà il est ravi la palme et nicolas
fait beau rêve pas preneur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors nounours tu es content de toi je
connais pas trop non tu as triché c'est
très vilain je ne le ferai plus pas trop
je vous le promets pour te punir tu ne
mangeras plus de miel ni demain ni après
demain on l'honore ce que je suis puis
bonne nuit les enfants allez vite vous
coucher et ne fait jamais comme nounours
fait tout pour
en deux
[Musique]